[موسيقى]
هذه هوليوود في هايلاند ،
عادةً ما تكون مشغولة جدًا ، إنها ممتلئة دائمًا
ولكن الآن إنها ميتة ، يمكنك في
الواقع رؤية جميع النجوم قاحلة ، نعم
تشعر وكأنها مساحة سلبية
الآن نحن في جراند سنترال  سوق
في وسط مدينة لوس أنجلوس ، يمكنك الحصول على
البيرة والنبيذ الآن هنا قهوة سمها ما شئت ،
يمكنك العيش هنا ، يأتي الآلاف من الناس
يوميًا خلال عطلات نهاية الأسبوع ، والآن
أصبحت مدينة أشباح تشبه
مدينة الأشباح ، من الغريب أن نراها كمدينة أشباح.  وقت الأشباح ،
لكن من الغريب جدًا أن نرى كيف
هو الآن ، لذلك لدينا رصيف سانتا
مونيكا ورائي مباشرة ، إنه
مكان ممتع حقًا للذهاب إليه للتسكع مع
الناس ، اذهب على الأفعوانية ، واستمتع
بالطعام الرائع ، انظر إلى فناني
الشوارع.  إنها مجرد تسعة من
عشرة ، نعم ، إنها مشكلة لا يمكنك فعلها
ولكن مرة أخرى أفهم أيضًا أنهم
لا يريدون أن يمرض الناس ، ومن الواضح أن
هناك حاجة لمحاولة القيام بشيء من
أجل الصحة العامة ولكن في نفس
الوقت  تدمير الاقتصاد
لا يوجد بائعون وهذا أمر
غريب ، إنه يضر بالاقتصاد بالتأكيد
حاول وافعل ما بوسعك لدعم
أعمالك المحلية ، ولا يزال الكثير منهم
مفتوحًا ولا يزالون يقومون بالتسليم في محاولة
للعثور على مكانك السعيد
بطريقة ما والأشياء الأخرى التي تفعلها أنا
يعني حاول القيام بأنشطة أخرى
تستمتع بها ولا تتطلب التسكع مع
أشخاص جدد ، فهي لا تزال موجودة
وستكون مفتوحة مرة أخرى ، أعني أن أعود في المرة القادمة ،
نعم ، سأعود قريبًا عندما يفتح كل شيء
رأسه للخروج من
ذلك  متحمسة للغاية ، سأقوم بالركض
على الشاطئ تمامًا مثل
[موسيقى]
أوه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حافظ على صحتك وتوقف هناك
وكن لطيفًا مع الجميع
[الموسيقى]
في هذا الحي العصري بطوكيو ،
المسرح هو  ضبط الفرقة جاهزة ،
قد لا يستمر العرض أبدًا في أكثر ما يخشاه
الغناء ، دع المحكمة تعلم أنني لا أعرف
متى سينتهي تفشي فيروس كورونا ،
يقول لك ذلك ، لقد كان كانام يدخر
لسنوات لفتح مكان للموسيقى الحية
يمكنه ذلك.  ر لدينا حفلة موسيقية معك  بالنسبة للجمهور ،
لديك وسادة يمكن أن تدوم لشهر واحد
ربما شهرين ، ماذا يحدث بعد ذلك
، يقول إن هذا المكان سيتم إغلاقه
دون أن يكون مفتوحًا على الإطلاق ، تمتم
للشركات الصغيرة التي تعمل بالفعل على دعم الحياة.
طُلب من سبع
محافظات ، بما في ذلك طوكيو
وأوساكا ، البقاء في منازلها فقط
للنشاط الاقتصادي الأساسي مثل النقل العام
والمتاجر الكبيرة التي ستستمر.
العائلات
وأصحاب الأعمال الصغيرة أيضًا
يفرضون رسومًا على مهلة التنفس
للشركات التي تعاني من ضائقة مالية ، ولا أعتقد أن
هناك أي شركة لم
تتأثر سلبًا إلا إذا كانت
تبيع أجهزة التنفس أو الأشياء التي تحتاجها حقًا.
126 مليونًا ،
حوالي 40 بالمائة من هؤلاء كانوا
قيد الاستخدام بالفعل  منذ يوم مضى ، كان جعل المزيد من
أجهزة التنفس يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ،
ربما لا تعاني مستشفيات طوكيو
من نفاد الأسرة في المدينة لمرضى فيروس كورونا ،
ليس لدى اليابان سوى سبعة أسرّة لوحدة العناية المركزة
لكل 100000 شخص
، وهو ما يمثل خُمس تحذيرات حكومة الولايات المتحدة
بالبقاء في المنزل
مصفف شعر takechi  أعمال سوزوكي
بأكثر من النصف ،
هل يمكنك النجاة من هذا الوباء المستنسخ
الذي يمكنني أن أفعله منها لا أعرف أنه
يقول إن الأمر يعتمد على المدة التي سيستغرقها هذا
إذا استمع الجميع للحكومة
واتخذوا إجراءات قوية أعتقد أن
هذا سيفعله في الوقت الحالي  إن إعطائي دروس تصميم المنزل
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي أخذته بعيدًا عن
فيروس كورونا أنا خائف من
مدخراتي كما يقول ، لكن شغفي
لن يموت هذا الحلم للدراسة في
نيويورك يومًا ما حلم لا يمكن أن يتحقق إلا
عندما يكون هذا الكابوس  أكثر من ريبلي
سي إن إن طوكيو